uh my colleague from the nfl network i'm
terrific yeah man how are you ian
i'm good rich what's happening i figured
i was interviewing malcolm jenkins i saw
you were on the screen i'm like let's
see if he
ian can join me in between hits on nfl
network so is that the plan that the
texans hope that they can put
the trade request genie back in the
bottle and and and
go to battle with uh desean watson is
that the plan in houston
yeah um i would say that that is the
plan they have yet
as far as i can tell yet to have
substantial conversations
if any conversations with desean watson
i mean i know the owner has gotten a
couple texts back
comic mayor i just don't know that nick
casiro has sat down with him
extensively and discussed everything yet
they do not want to trade him
um nick casirio's words were pretty
strong
saying he had zero interest in trading
the player
um david coe's words were stronger
saying
the reason i'm in this position is i
know he's going to be a houston texan um
and and all that is noteworthy and i do
not mean to
sort of minimize that stuff um it just
it's hard for me to do this without
thinking about dave gettleman saying
about odell we didn't sign odell
to trade him and then trading so uh
jamal adams pledging to be a jet for
life than asking his way out of the jets
like
four months later so words or words um i
know teams are not going to stop trying
well i mean
and and your talks with people close to
watson or watson or his camp
i mean is this delusional is this a
delusional approach because it also
opens up the texans too if watson says
yeah
i still want out now they've got a new
general manager
and and coach that was that has been
rejected
by the heart and soul of the team and
and and the number one in the heart
number four in the program number one in
the hearts of of fans then they
then this has been rejected at least if
they were moving on
now they would say well he he wanted out
we're gonna have a fresh start
this is kind of a risky play don't you
think yeah i think they've already sort
of been rejected so that
to me that not like that ship is sale
but that card has already been played
like they're already
he's already telling them he doesn't
want to be there he's already telling
them he doesn't want to work with them
so
if it lasts a couple months of rejection
like it's already been rejection
so i think they've already seen that
what is um
what is interesting is it's not actually
the higher of nick casirio that deshawn
watson doesn't like
it's not actually the higher david
culley that desean watson doesn't like
it's the way the owner treated him in
not involving him with the serial hire
promising that he would have a say and
then not giving him a say promising him
that
he would interview coaches he hears good
things about
they did interview eric the enemy but
did not interview robert sala
um that's the frustration it's not the
frustration of
um you know who actually was hired it's
more of the process
so i say this to add i don't think
deshawn watson has any ill will turn
nicosia or david collins
it's all the owner well that's not going
to change i i was peripherally trying to
keep track of this while interviewing
again malcolm jenkins in the previous
segment
and uh i didn't see cal mcnair was he
not on the zoom
he was not as a matter of fact wow
nope oh wow which
you know is obviously interesting and
extremely noteworthy
um however i would say that yes um
but you know most most owners are there
for introductory press conferences for
coaches as you know
most um i do not think it was the best
for the houston texans to have cal
mcnair up there today
the way nicosia and david culley handled
it was fine
you know the patriots very famously do
only what's best for their team
i do not think it was best for the
houston texans to have cow mcnair go up
there and
not be great um as opposed to having
kasiro and kali do well up there so then
so then
ian rap report few more minutes left
with my nfl network colleague here so
then
um the way that they approached it was
let's say
we have no intention of trading him and
i'm here because i know he's going to be
here
from the general manager and coach
respectively which which
gets us through the day um and now comes
what are the inflection points that
would that would maybe spur a deadline
here
uh contractually anything the draft is
obviously one
but what else might spur something
outside of watson
uh calling somebody in the nfl media and
saying let's do a one-on-one sit down
and then
he completely blows it all up like what
what outside of all that
are our inflection here the only real
thing is the start of the league year
which if you you know i i know you host
a
uh very well respected show i am
currently a guest on it i know you like
things to talk about
if you are interested in talking about
deshaun watson from now until
march 17th you're probably in luck um
you have to trade them before the start
of the league year to me
because no team is going to say we're
going to invest you know
40 or it's not 40 but say 29 million
dollars per year i think is what's left
on each
each year that's the average we're not
going to invest almost 30 million
dollars per year
in late april it's going to be in march
because you need to know what you have
in free agency so
if it doesn't happen by march 17th then
we're really headed to a long standoff
and is he going to sit out i mean
historically not a lot of players have
um brent williams did but that was for
sort of a
different injury reason um
and i don't think deshawn watkins has
any injuries so
you know we might be headed to a long
standoff i just the player
historically rarely sit down if that's
the case before i let you go ian
let's talk quickly the eagles
introduction of nick ciriani that
happened in the hour before the david
culley introduction
in in houston and it seemed like siriani
as i said on the air
we have our first punt of the siriani or
uh era
uh where he basically said he wouldn't
even commit to an open competition like
it just seemed like hey i just got here
and i'm not even close to giving you an
answer on the quarterback situation did
i
did i kind of carry all that correctly
or what did i miss
from from that in press conference that
you clean sometimes the punch is a very
good play
sometimes you know instead of turning it
over there's a win i think
yeah um i think for for nick ciriani
the most interesting thing to me he said
was
that he couldn't give an answer on
whether carson would be here
because he said all the right words he
said
um you know we have two top-notch
quarterbacks
he wouldn't quite say there's going to
be a camp competition but he didn't rule
it out
but the only thing that matters is
carson wentz going to be there um
and the fact that he couldn't
definitively say yes he is
makes me think that this is much more
open-ended than this is the guy who's
gonna fix carson end of story
that's what that meant to me because you
know if nick ciriani was hired only to
fix carson wentz
then he would say carson's definitely
going to be here he did not say that
that was noteworthy but i mean for
him to make the decision though again
it's the 53 man he confirmed is going to
be howie roseman and then the day
of the game is going to be him but uh
isn't
doug peterson you know wasn't part of
the reason why he was let go is because
he wanted to move on from whence and
that was not the case that that was not
going to happen
is i'm trying to square the peterson
firing with the
the siriani conversation right now
i got the sense that um
i got the sense that the reason one of
the reasons for the doug peterson firing
was about staff
that he wanted to promote from within
and kind of keep continuity
they wanted bigger bolder highers
outside the organization
he did not want them to tell him what to
do with staffing
and i really got the sense that he was
just
very much over it like it is five years
facing you know jeff mclean and his
media friends and silly like that's all
that's a lot
and those and those are the nice ones
you know like what happens when he goes
into a deli
you know um i got the sense he pushed
back push back and then was like okay
just i think we're good here yeah all
right last one for you
because again i know you're chasing news
truly last one what is going on with
goff and the rams what is happening here
i mean
if jalen ramsey was on a a zoom last
night with deandre hopkins our
our uh our colleague mj acosta ruiz and
also
uh prime uh the coach at jackson state
they're all
and and ramsey's like we all know where
desean's going he's coming here to l.a
and
and hopkins was like get out of here but
um
what it what is happening with golf in
the rams best you can
suss out here for me um they want to get
better at the quarterback position
and i think that is very clear and they
paid off a lot of money and you know the
rams
have obviously done things well they're
in the playoffs they have a playoff win
they have had several homegrown players
who've gotten contract extensions that
have not worked out that's
that's tough to deal with um for a lot
of reasons but
um i think with jared goff they have to
get better at quarterback and
if it's not with him i think they're
they're okay with that i mean yes
like contractually it hurts capitalize
it hurts
but it hurts more to have a quarterback
that isn't good enough but um
he obviously has got the has gone the
wrong way for them and they need to fix
it but i guess then the difference is
it hurts you know at least the the
eagles have jalen
and they're refusing to have it hurt
their cap if you see where i'm going
here
by keeping wence but did the rams isn't
the contract pretty much the same
wouldn't that be the same price it
seemed like the rams whatever's
whatever the eagles are refusing to uh
move on from with wence because of the
contract
it seems like the rams don't have that
concern is that the
the fact of it yeah i mean both both
contracts are tradable
they really are i mean everyone says a
lot of things i think if somebody wanted
either of those guys definitively
you could definitely trade the contract
because it's only
i mean the cap hits you're ready getting
killed on the cap
if you trade you know 25 million dollars
of salary
it actually helps you because it lessens
the cap charge that's already on the
books
you're ready it's already hurting so
trading the guy actually just
helps a little bit um so i think both
are tradable
ian thanks for the uh for the call i'll
see on nfl network in a few minutes
thanks the call brother all right rich
appreciate it as i ian
rappaport answering the the text in the
commercial break can you do now yes can
you come on
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here